europese groepsfase zitten erop
en dit zijn de potentiële tegenstanders van PSV
feyenoord en Ajax in de volgende ronde
PSV die zal het meest
met samengeknepen billen kijken naar de loting
want zij worden namelijk gekoppeld
aan 1 van de groepswinnaars van de champions league
dat zijn Bayern München
real Madrid real
zo zie je dat atletico Madrid
borisje Dortmund
Manchester city en FC Barcelona
feyenoord is door de derde plek in de champions league
veroordeeld tot de Europa league
daarin wordt het gekoppeld aan 1 van de nummers 2
uit Europa league
dat zijn essenfryburg
olenpick Marseille
Sparta Praag sporting
Lissabon to loser
staderents azroma en carabach
Ajax heeft het donderdagavond met de eerste europese
groepsoverwinning dit seizoen ten koste van aika
Athene geplaatst voor de conference league
en wordt daar gekoppeld
aan 1 nummer 2
dat zijn de sloom van bratislava a
agent dynamo zaak HEB modeblind
leaguia washou
finish faros
eindgracht Frankfurt en ludo Gore hats
aanstaande maandagmiddag wordt er geloot
drop je voorspelling voor de loting
hier bij ons in de comments